최근에 서울의 봄이 인기가 좀
많잖아요 그래서 서울의 봄 출연진
중에 빌딩을 소유하고 계신 분이
계십니다 제일 주 주연으로 나왔던
전두광 역할을 맡은 황정민 배우랑
그리고 이태신 사령관 역할을 맡은 그
정우석 님이 빌딩을 소유하고 있습니다
그래서 오늘 두 분이 어떤 빌딩을
매입했는지 오늘 좀 다뤄보도록
하겠습니다 전두광 역할을 맡은 황정민
배우 같은 경우에는 도산공원 앞쪽에
건물이 있어요 위치가 좀 굉장히 좋은
위치고 도산 공원을 바로 끼고
있습니다 그래서 여기 변에 건물을
가지고 있고 지금 이겁니다 그래서
이거를 2017년도에 84억 매입을
했고요 부부 공동명의로 매입을 했고
대출은 실체 문은 한 40억 정도
받았습니다 그래서 뭐 취득세 감안해서
현금은 한 50억 정도 들어간 것으로
좀 예상이 되고요 어 일단 이쪽
지역은 일종 일반 주거 지역이에요
그래서 용적률이 150%까지 돼 있고
지금이 건물도 거의 좀 꽉차 있는
그런 건물입니다 그리고 지금 임차
갤러리가 대부분 사용 중에 있고 지금
뭐 임대 수익은 그래도 공실 없이 잘
나오는 것으로 좀 예상이 됩니다
연면적이 한 120평 대지가 한
67평 정도 됩니다 근데 일단이
건물에는 승강기는 따로 없는 거
같더라고요 그래서 건축물 대장을
보니까 따로 승강기는 없는 거 같고
주차 세대 그다음 이제 근생으로 돼
있고 2017년도에는 이쪽이 좀
도산공원 인근이 좀 활발히 발달되지
않았었거든요 근데 최근에 좀 이쪽
인근에 좀 분위기가 많이 바뀌면서
가격도 덩달아 올라갔습니다 그때
매입했을 당시에 땅 가격으로 봤을 때
한 1억 2천 정도 됐는데 지금은 한
2억 거의 한 초중반까지 될 것으로
좀 예상이 돼서 총 금액은 거의 한
뭐 140억 150억 아지 시세가
형성되 있을 것이라고 좀 예상이
됩니다 두 번째로 어 정호석 님은
도산대로의 건물 있으세요 제가
좋아하는 건물 중에 하난데 여기
도산대로 청담동에 여기 코너 변의
건물을 가지고 있습니다 그리고 요거는
좀 재밌는게 이정재 배우님이랑 같이
공동 투자를 했어요 그래서 지금이
건물입니다 어 2020년도에 330억
원에 매입을 했고 대출은 약 한
220억 정도 대출을 받았습니다
그리고 지금이 땅은 165평 연면적은
429명이고 지하 1층에 지상 4층
정도의 건물입니다 근데 지금 여기가
토지 이용 계획 보면은 노선 상업지에
그래서 상업지 일반 주거 지역이랑
같이 있어서 용적률이 더 나옵니다
일단은 기존 건물을 좀 최대한 살려
가지고 리모델링해서 지금 쓰고 있는
거 같은데 땅에 가치 는 더 높습니다
그래서 건물을 나중에 올리게 되면
10층 이상 이렇게도 신축이 좀
가능한 그런 땅이라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 그래서 그때 당시에 대지
평당가로 한 2억 원 정도에 매입을
했는데 지금 시세는 대략 한 500억
정도 어 될 것으로 좀 예상이 됩니다
정우성 배우님이 가지고 계신이 땅은
청담동에서 굉장히 좀 좋은 위치에
있는 땅이에요 그래서 앞으로 좀 더
가치가 올라갈 만한 어 그런 땅이라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다 그 앞으로 좀
더 올릴 여지도 있고 일단은 두 분
사례를 좀 좀 봤는데 되게 위치
좋은데 좀 잘 매입하실 거 같아요
특히 정우성 님은 더 그렇습니다
황정민 님은 이제 일종에
매입하셨으면
지금 시세 오른 것도 정우성 외우
님이 매입한 미치가 어 시세가 더
많이 올랐고요 여러분들도 어 이렇게
빌딩 보실 때 항상 이렇게 토지 이용
계획을 항상 좀 먼저 보시려고 생각을
하시면 좋을 것 같습니다 서울의
모험을 보면 저도 좀 굉장히 화가
많이 났는데 어 일단 좀 제가 어
재미삼아서 우연찮게 또 두 분이
건물을 또 가지고 계셔서 영상을 찍게
됐습니다 그래서 다음에도 좀 이렇게
이슈가 될 만한 뭐 연예인 분이
투자한 사례가 있다라고 하면은
계속계속 제가 좀 촬영해서 어
여러분들한테 좀 알려 드리도록
하겠습니다 그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지
하고요 다음 시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다